est-ce que vous saviez que Skoda faisait
des scooters on est ici à Prague on va
se faire un petit tour de scooter alors
regardez c'est be riders c'est la marque
de scooter électrique de Skoda livre
service en tout cas ici à Prague on va
se faire un retour avec mon bon vieux
coco derrière à mon avis ça va envoyer
du bois
[Musique]
mais voilà après avoir fait je sais pas
combien on a fait une tête une trentaine
de kilomètres d'empreinte on se
électrique regardez signer Skoda est-ce
que vous le saviez vous ne savez pas du
tout que Skoda avait des scouts
électriques je trouve ça assez marrant
parce que j'adore le deux roues avec ma
charlotte encore plus magnifique et puis
bien évidemment c'est toujours la
question alors on le voit au niveau de
la mobilité la mobilité évolue on va de
plus en plus de marques arriver avec des
solutions un peu complètes et en fait ce
que faire ce qu'on a c'est se
transformer en étant un constructeur
d'automobile pour arriver à un
constructeur immobilier et ils font
notamment ici avec leur scout qu'on
retrouve à Prague donc je sais pas si ça
pourrait vous tenter vous bottez de
venir faire un petit tour de scout Skoda
marqué votre bien évidemment dans les
commentaires